I mean bureaucracy is just antithetical
to the creative genius ancient Athens
Renaissance Florence enlightenment
Edinboro why have certain places at
certain times created such monumental
leaps in innovation this is the question
at the heart of travel writer Eric
whiners latest book the geography of
genius I was interested in the content
of these places what they produce but
more than that I was interested in the
processes is really a book about process
about how creative genius happens in
what are the circumstances I believe in
the power of place and the power of
culture to shape our lives in unexpected
ways whether it's happiness or
spirituality or creative genius when I
saw your book one of the first books I
thought about was Richard Florida's
rides in the creative class right tell
me you have some issues with his diary
can you talk about that I mean I think
he's right in pinpointing as I do place
in this equation the place matters so I
totally agree with him about that
um I don't agree with his sort of
formula for attracting the creative
class you know he says you need the
three T's technology talent and
tolerance well I probably agree with
tolerance other like call it diversity
slightly different diversity of ideas as
well as people but talent and technology
or technology no I mean I think that
that throughout history there were in
great places that didn't produce much
techni in the way of technology be it
Florence or Athens they produced great
art and poetry and philosophy they
didn't care much for technology and
talent is the result of a golden age you
have a golden age and then talent grows
out of it
so I don't really buy into the notion
that if you create a sort of hip you
know friendly gay friendly atmosphere
with lots of ethnic restaurants and
theater districts that you then attract
creative people you won't track people
but if you look at look at New York the
creative class as it were is always
moving to difficult places
you you need more than just comfort and
interesting neighborhoods to be creative
you actually need constraints and you
need hardship and that unfortunately
doesn't sell to city planners they don't
want to hear that you need to create
hardship for people but the research is
pretty clear that constraints Drive
creativity traveling the globe whiner
looked at the locations and cultures
that fostered history's greatest minds
piecing together a list of ingredients
he believes played a vital role let's
talk about chaos Kass is good a little
bit of chaos is good there was a
neuroscientist named Walter Freeman who
studied the brains of rabbits and hooked
up the rabbits to EE jeez and then
introduced them to smells some they were
familiar with and some they weren't and
he noticed whenever the rabbit was
introduced to a new smell their EEG
their brainwave activity entered a
chaotic state what Freeman called and I
think it's a great term the I don't know
state and if you think about it all
creative breakthroughs are preceded by
that I don't know state and in fact I
talked about this in my book the
importance of ignorance in all great
people and great places all these places
there's an element of tension and
discomfort even and and often there's a
catastrophe that precedes a golden age
whether it's Athens being sacked by the
Persians and then being rebuilt by
Pericles and building the Acropolis and
these wonders we still admire today or
Florence being hit by the Black Death
the bubonic plague and no more than two
generations later we have the blossoming
of the Renaissance bad things can lead
to good things and that goes into
disorder chaos the sort of idea this
Rapide some disruption in order to grow
something new I think so I think that
the pot has to be stirred if you're
fully invested in the status quo either
as a person or as a place you're
unlikely to create genius because you're
you're too comfortable and if I look at
the individuals in my book they all were
to some extent an outsider they all
either had a difficult childhood or
like Freud they were immigrants and as a
Jew he was an outsider and so they're
never fully invested in the status quo
there are a number of places including
Qatar at London you see places all
around that are trying to build the
Silicon Valley Blank right and
inevitably fail you know I wish I could
sit here and tell you that there's a
formula and if you apply the formula
you'll have the next Silicon Valley and
I would be a very wealthy man let's be
honest if I had that formula I probably
would have time to sit with you because
I believe I'd be oh my god you do anyway
yeah exactly
and the reason I have times because
there's no formula there's no absolute
formula to do it and you're right these
efforts have failed whether it's you
know Silicon Oasis in Dubai Thames
Valley in England they fail again
because you can't transplant in a
culture in Silicon Valley I really
believe as a culture and Silicon
Valley's success has very little to do
with technology almost nothing its
product is technology right but the meet
the means is social and cultural it's a
creative ecology and one thing that
Silicon Valley does have in common with
ancient Athens is both were moochers
they borrowed or if you're feeling less
generous stole from other places
the Athenians didn't invent the idea of
making statues for instance they borrow
that from the Egyptians but then they
perfected it Plato said what the Greeks
borrow from foreigners they perfect and
look at Silicon Valley that the
cellphone wasn't invented there was
invented in Illinois the idea of venture
capital wasn't invented arrows invented
in New York but what does Silicon Valley
do it perfects these ideas it it slots
that I'm in it discerns and separates
the good ideas from the bad ones
it says a-ha that's a good idea that'll
fly and then it provides a runway for it
to take off towards the end of the book
you said we need to begin thinking of
creativity not as a private indulgence
but as a public good part of the Commons
what do you mean by that
I say what I don't mean I don't mean
that the government should be in the
creativity business I'll tell you a
story when I was in China there's a lot
of hand-wringing in China now about the
innovation gap as they call it and
people will say openly and complain and
moan and groan everything is made in
China but nothing is invented here and
actually I swear on TV there was a panel
discussion and they and one of the
panelists said well we we need to you
need the government to have an
innovation program for the country the
way they've had a infrastructure program
building high-speed rail in the highways
and that sort of thing I mean it's
almost laughable
that that doesn't work but I do believe
that as they say in the book we get the
geniuses that we want and that we
deserve right we treat genius like it's
almost like shooting stars you know that
just you can't predict them they're
amazing and beautiful when you see them
in the night sky but you don't know when
they'll be coming and there's nothing
you can do about it and I don't think
that's true there are very talented
classical composers today but no one
that we would consider on the level of a
Mozart or Beethoven or Hyden
now why is that is it because these
people are not as talented as Mozart no
I would say it's for two reasons one is
the best and the brightest
now are gonna head out to Silicon Valley
or maybe Wall Street or do it startup
right that that's where the recognition
is that's one problem but the second
problem is even if you do buck the trend
and say I love classical music and you
become a darn good one you don't get the
recognition that Mozart once did if you
look at the creativity as a Commons you
would say well of course this is who our
geniuses are going to be because we
value technology we value what he
created if we were to value something
else we were too difficult a different
kind of genius and again that doesn't
mean you have a government genius
programmer innovation program but it
does mean that you take some
responsibility for the geniuses that we
get
you